أنا هنا أتشبث بجانب هوة جليدية عميقة
لم أكن أعتقد أنني سأنتهي في أي وقت مضى في
مكان مثل
ألاسكا
هذه الولاية المهيبة تضم
أعلى 13 قمة في الولايات المتحدة على بعد 45000
ميل من الخط الساحلي والحياة البرية الوفيرة
أيضًا  لقد كان على قائمة الجرافات الخاصة بي ، لذا
توجهت إلى بلدة سوارد على بعد حوالي
120 ميلًا جنوب المرسى
حيث قابلت صديقي القديم
جنوم ترافيلوسيتي المتجول سعيدًا لأنك تستطيع جعله بوب
الآن يمكنك أن تقرر هل أنت هنا
للاسترخاء أو  استكشاف ، هل يمكننا القيام بالأمرين في
الواقع ، لذا قمنا أولاً بالقفز في
رحلة بحرية في الطبيعة
اكتشفنا لماذا لا نذهب بسهولة إلى ألاسكا مع
جولات مضيق كيني نحن نقاتل
عبر مضيق بحري متجه إلى خليج
ألاسكا ، نعم ، لقد أردت دائمًا القدوم
إلى  الدولة التاسعة والأربعون يومًا ما حسنًا ، دعنا
ننتهز يومًا ما اليوم ، أنا جاهز
لأننا خرجنا بحثًا عن
الحوت الأحدب بعيد المنال ، كان المحيط
يعج بالحياة البرية من استيقاظ قطة سوداء ،
ربما ينبغي أن أضع
غطاء محركي على خنازير البحر وسيرك من
البفن  نوع  من المشي حول
هذا
النحو ، واجهنا مستعمرة من أسود البحر النجمية أكبر أنواع أسد البحر
ويزن ما يصل إلى 2500 رطلاً ، كان اثنان من
الذكور الكبيرة يتقاتلان على مجموعة من
الإناث تسترخى على الصخور أدناه
اللائي كان من الواضح أن الفائزين هنا ما زالوا
يأملون في الحصول على  مشاهدة الحيتان لقد سجلت الوصول
مع القبطان جريج رؤية جيدة جدًا
وفرصة جيدة لرؤية واحدة ، لذا
قمت بتجنيد مكالمة التزاوج الخاصة بي التي تم تدريبها جيدًا لرسمها
من أعماق أوه بوب ، انظر إلى الساعة العاشرة
، وهو حوت أحدب شمال المحيط الهادئ
يمكن أن تنمو إلى ما يقرب من 60 قدمًا ،
ومع انتقالنا بعيدًا إلى متنزه كيناي
فيوردس الوطني ، بدا أن
الفصول تتغير وما
ظهر أمامنا أخيرًا كان يخطف
الأنفاس في نهر آيلتس الجليدي بمياه المد والجزر وهو يتدهور وينهار
في البحر
لذا بوب أنا  أراهن أنك ترغب في الاستيقاظ
فوق أحد هذه الأنهار الجليدية ،
لذلك اتضح أن جنوم المتجول لم
يكن يمزح بوب قابل مايك الطيار
من مروحيات الماراثون ، حسنًا ،
أينما كنت  بالضبط لذلك نحن
نطير عبر جبال كيني هنا بالضبط ،
ما هو هذا النهر الجليدي الذي على وشك زيارته ، نحن
متجهون مباشرة إلى نهر جودوين الجليدي ، وضعنا مايك
على سطح القمر واجتمعنا
مع مرشدنا كيف تفعل أنا بوب
تريفور إعدام  لم أكن أعلم
أن الرجال لديهم سر بالنسبة لي في أعالي
النهر الجليدي
وتحذير متكرر لا يقع في
تلك الحفرة ، حسنًا ،
ستموت بالتأكيد إذا وقعت
في هذا الثقب ،
ثم لسوء حظي اكتشفت أن
الخطة بالنسبة لي  هو نزول إلى
حفرة عميقة في الجليد تسمى الصدع ، يا
إلهي ، هذا هو لجميع الأغراض العملية بلا
قاع
ليس في جورجيا بعد الآن ،
وهو ما يعيدنا إلى حيث بدأنا
بالأرض تحاول أن تبتلعني
بالكامل أوه بوب الأرض لن تذهب  لكي
تبتلع ، أنت الآن تستمتع بنفسك وتبدأ في
الصعود مرة أخرى إلى الأعلى
بوب لطيف ، نعم هناك نذهب بوب لطيف وعلى
الرغم من كل الصعاب ، فقد وصلت
حافة الصدع إلى مشهد مرحب به للغاية
لصديقي العزيز بوب في أيدينا ،
كنت دائمًا بأمان  أنت  أنت على حق في 100
ولكن لا يزال بإمكانك الاحتفال مثل
ملكك في العالم
[موسيقى]